jQuery includes some handy ways to get
inset CSS properties of elements and
also they get inset classes of elements
I already have some HTML code set up
here you can see just a few different
elements they have some classes on it I
also have some CSS here just a few
things the red class and the big class
and then I've already started an action
for a button using jQuery we have the
jQuery selector to select the button and
then I've added a click event and then
I'm just about to put in what happens
when you click the event and I'm gonna
show you how to work with CSS and
classes first if you need help adding
jQuery to your project you can check out
my getting started with jQuery video so
first I'm going to show you how to get
CSS properties we can use the CSS method
and we're gonna get the font size
property so I've selected the paragraph
now this is just going to give us the
font size of the first paragraph element
and we want to display that so let's put
it in the console console that log so we
have the we selected the paragraph dot
CSS and when you get to see us us of
font size so I'm gonna click here and
you can see in the console 16 pixels so
this is in camelcase but you can also
put it how you'd normally see in CSS
with a dash here and then if I click
there again it's just going to show the
same thing 16 pixels now we can also
select the paragraph tag with the big
class and 36 pixels because it's bigger
now let's take off the console dot log
because instead of getting the property
we're gonna set the property would pass
in two things the class name font size
and what we're gonna set it to you let's
set to a hundred pixels so now big is
going to be even bigger
click the element oh it's even bigger to
100 pixels now so you just do dot CSS
the first thing that you pass in is the
CSS property and the second thing you
pass in is what you want to set that
property to we can also set multiple CSS
properties at once by passing in an
object so let's delete that and I'm
going to create an object which is just
surrounded by these
braces and we're going to pass in key
value pairs so when we're passing key
value pairs you're gonna have to use the
camel case for the name here whenever
you're passing in as a string you can
use either way but either the dashes or
the camel case but if you're passing in
and as a property name like this or if
you're passing it as a key you're gonna
have to use camel case so we're gonna
set this to 50 pixels
, now we're gonna change the color to
blue and let's just add a background
color Oh a comma here now instead of
just doing the big class we're gonna
select all the paragraph elements so
let's see what happens here
I'm gonna click the button and you can
see each paragraph element has the blue
text and the yellow background and it's
bigger now it's not recommended to use
the CSS method as a setter in production
ready code because it's generally best
practice to keep presentational
information out of the JavaScript code
see we're adding actual CSS to the
JavaScript code and often you'll want to
just keep your CSS in your CSS file and
then just add or remove classes if you
want to change the CSS so I'm just going
to comment that button out and then add
the same code again and we're going to
change what the button does
I just want both still in here so if you
click on the link for the code in the
description of this video you can see
both ways of doing it now let's select
the h1 element and we're gonna do add
class that's how you add a class and
jQuery so we're gonna pass in the class
name and the class pass in red first
let's go back to how it was before okay
if I click to click me you can see that
h1 changed to red because we add the red
class we can also remove classes so here
I'm going to select paragraphs and
instead of add class I'm going to do
remove class and instead of removing
class read and remove class big so I'm
going to click the button and you can
see the paragraph aren't big anymore
because the big has been removed from
every paragraph tag only one of them had
the tag to begin what though so another
thing you can do is toggle class
we show you that instead of removeclass
I'm gonna do toggleclass
and I'm still selecting every paragraph
element so now when we click the button
it'll just switch see which paragraph is
big is switching so we see they're
turning on the big class if it doesn't
already have the big class or it's
turning off the big class it already has
it it's toggling bless I'm going to show
you is how to check if an element has a
class we can use the has class method
we're gonna check if the element h2 has
the class big and we could put this into
an if statement but I'm going to just do
console that log okay let's try this
false it does not have the class big but
if we change this to class red true it
does have the class big okay thanks for
watching my name is Bo Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good